[Music]
on this Thursday night another sobering
benchmark 1-hundred thousand Canadians
tested positive for Kovac 19 we dig into
the demographics and the new app aimed
at controlling the spread a former
American National Security Advisor takes
aim at his old boss I don't think he has
the confidence to carry out the job the
new book the US president doesn't want
you to read eradicating racism the
tragedy that was a catalyst for change
in to Alberta Communities and she was a
voice of reassurance and resilience
remembering singer virile in whose songs
of hope span generations will be
national we've done a freezin good
evening and thanks for joining us it has
now been 100 days since the World Health
Organization officially declared a
pandemic and tonight Canada has reached
a new threshold in the number of cases
more than 100,000 people have tested
positive in Canada for kovat 19 it's
data from the hardest-hit provinces of
Ontario and Quebec that's pushing the
caseload up Ontario reported 173 new
infections today and three more deaths
more than 8,200 people across Canada are
now known to have died from covin 19
testing and contact tracing are crucial
to stopping the spread and today the
Prime Minister announced a new
smartphone app that will be tested in
Ontario it's designed to notify users if
they've come into close contact with
someone who has tested positive but the
app is voluntary and will only work if
the majority of people use it I'll have
more on that in just a moment first Eric
Sorenson takes a closer look at the Cova
19 curve in Canada as we approach the
middle of 2020 for the ninth straight
day Nova Scotia reported no new cases of
kovat 19 it's now bursting the bubble
allowing groups of up to 10 to gather
without physical distancing but in BC a
new outbreak has been traced from
asymptomatic cases at mission Memorial
Hospital to two long-term care
facilities it shows as the country opens
up kovat 19 is still lurking of the 100
thousand cases in the country more than
87,000 were in Quebec and Ontario they
accounted for the huge surge in April
and May with numbers falling the
National curve has come way down but not
disappeared there's gonna be a bit of a
tightrope walk between opening up the
economy between going about our
day-to-day lives with some modifications
to really reduce the spread of
transmission community as we reach
100,000 cases in Canada kovin 19 effects
age groups differently first here's the
population distribution in the country
from age 0 to 19 and then every 20 years
and there are far fewer Canadians age 80
and over the number of cases of kovat
nineteen aligns pretty much with the
adult age groups but there are far fewer
cases among children and far more cases
for those that are elderly and look at
the number of deaths from kovat 19 for
those aged 0 to 19 virtually zero for
working age adults from age 20 to 59
only 3% of the deaths the numbers rise
over the age of 60 and again as you get
above the age of 80 just 4% of the
population has 72 percent of the deaths
but while kids are at lower risk there's
still a risk and when they go back to
school
the virus could begin to spread could
get this infection and bring it home to
their mom and dad or worse bring it home
to their grandmother or grandfather
I think it's unrealistic that we can
build a wall around an older age cohort
and protect them while having this
infection spread through a younger age
forward unfortunately life doesn't work
like that to keep the virus from
spreading Ontario plans to roll out
mobile testing units at farms with
migrant workers and more widely the
province is set to test a new contact
tracing app next month a made in Ontario
app will equip the public with a new and
innovative tool to alert them when they
may have been exposed to Kovac 19 using
the app will be voluntary but if enough
people download it it would be one more
tool to keep covert 19 in check as the
province and the country
open up Eric Sorenson Global News
Toronto as Eric said if not enough
people download the app it won't be
effective here's the simple version of
how it works people who test positive
upload their results anonymously to the
app called kovat alert using a temporary
code given to them by a health care
provider the app would run in the
background of your phone and when your
phone gets within range of others with
the app they trade codes and create an
encrypted record if you encounter
someone with the app who is positive
you'd received an alerts that you've
been exposed and be encouraged to
contact local public health authorities
the app will use Bluetooth technology
rather than GPS for connecting to other
devices in close range the world is
still hoping for a vaccine and
the World Health Organization is says
it's optimistic hundreds of millions of
doses could be available later this year
and two billion doses by the end of 2021
the w-h-o is chief scientists admits
there's lots of uncertainty in vaccine
development but about ten potential
vaccine candidates have reached the
stage of human clinical trials many
wealthy countries are already making
deals with pharmaceutical companies to
order doses the w-h-o says it's drawing
up plans to help decide who should get
the first doses once a vaccine is
approved but it admits it has no way to
enforce that should it go only to the
countries which have paid for it or
capable of paying for it to cover their
own populations or should it go to
protect frontline health workers are the
most vulnerable people so this is
something I think the global community
needs to discuss now to Canada and
politics the NDP leader jug meets
Singh's accusation that a bloc québécois
MP is racist has boiled over into a
second day of tense exchanges in Ottawa
Levesque expressing that he was us to
leave the house and I asked once again
to not recognize him today today the
bloc québécois Whip asked the Speaker of
the House not to allow Singh to speak
during Question Period yesterday the NDP
leader was kicked out of the House of
Commons for refusing to apologize for
calling the bloc québécois House leader
a racist Singh claimed the block MP
dismissed an NDP motion calling out
systemic racism in the RCMP and used a
hand gesture to symbolically bat Singh
away this is what Prime Minister Trudeau
said today about Singh's comments it is
not for me to criticize any Canadian
particularly not the only racialized
leader in the House of Commons for
making other people uncomfortable by
calling them out for not recognizing
systemic discrimination mr. Singh is a
good person I always thought that and I
still think that he somehow dropped the
ball and I hope you will take it back
you Francois blah shet that the block
leader wants Singh to apologize for
painting his party as racist and he says
he wishes the Speaker of the House of
Commons would respond with a more severe
penalty for the NDP leader than a
24-hour suspension the four contenders
for the leadership of the federal
Conservative Party face off tonight in a
debate the name of the game is not just
to become Tory leader but to have what
it takes to become Prime Minister and
that means defeating Justin Trudeau our
chief political correspondent David akin
is in Ottawa tonight David are any of
these candidates on that path and
showing that kind of momentum well not
just yet Donna but there are plenty of
people in the party who hope that
tonight's English language leaders
debate is the start of a showcase for
the next leader not just a conservative
partisans but to a broader audience to
all Canadians who will vote in the next
general election the leading candidate
right now is Peter MacKay co-founder of
the party along with Stephen Harper
he served in Harper's cabinet but he's
been out of politics for five years and
he wants back in Ontario MP Aaron
O'Toole also served in Harper's cabinet
O'Toole ran for leader in 2017 but
finished third in the race that Andrew
Shearer one but now O'Toole is nipping
at McKay's heels now it appears that
neither Mackay Nord
O'Toole will have enough votes to win
the leadership on their own they're
going to need second or third ballot
support from the two other candidates
les Lin Lewis is a Toronto lawyer who
has never held office and Derek Sloan is
a first term Ontario MP both Lewis and
Sloan are social conservatives and are
running as such Sloan in particular and
that means both mckay and O'Toole have
to appeal to conservative voters who
want to address abortion conversion
therapy right-to-die legislation and
other social conservative issues but as
McKay himself said after the last
election the party's social conservative
bent was the quote stinking albatross
that held it back from beating Justin
Trudeau and the Liberals and there's
your leadership race theme so far how
does this party square the twenty or
thirty percent of its membership you
want to talk about social conservative
values with the goal of winning an
election when
most voters do not think those issues
are a top priority Donna all right David
Aiken thank you the American Supreme
Court has blocked president Trump's
attempt to cancel an Obama era program
that provided legal protections to
unauthorized immigrants who arrived in
the US as children the policy known as
daca protected young undocumented
immigrants known as dreamers from being
deported the policy allows young people
raised without legal immigration status
to get renewable permits to live and
work in the u.s. nearly 800,000 young
people were left in limbo when President
Trump rescinded the policy in September
of 2017 calling it illegal today's
Supreme Court ruling called that
arbitrary and capricious the decision
blocks the administration from shutting
down the program a man who was once a
key figure in Trump's White House is now
stabbing him in the back John Bolton a
former national security adviser has
written a tell-all book Bolton says
Trump is unfit for office Trump calls
him a liar you get the idea it's not the
first book written by a former insider
and as Jackson prosecco reports it's not
clear what if any long-term impact
Bolton's book will have once a fixture
looming over the shoulder of President
Donald Trump former national security
adviser John Bolton has little good to
say about his ex-boss in a forthcoming
tell-all book he describes an erratic
stunningly uninformed and unqualified
commander-in-chief I don't think he's
fit for office I don't think he has the
confidence to carry out the job there
really isn't any guiding principle that
I was able to discern other than what's
good for Donald Trump's reelection
Boulton recounts Trump's willingness to
interfere in domestic investigations to
please foreign dictators the pattern
looked like obstruction of justice as a
way of life he writes Bolton also
suggests Trump wanted China's help with
his re-election campaign hoping the
country would buy more agricultural
products to help him win farm states in
2020 matching Trump's own public calls
for election interference and by the way
likewise China just started
investigation into the Biden Bolton
alleges Trump even endorsed China's mass
detention camps for
Muslim minority weaker population Trump
said that she should go ahead with
building the camp's which Trump thought
was exactly the right thing to do he
claims they fill in the blanks of what
we as Americans should all be concerned
about with this president but the
allegations made by bolt and have not
endeared him to either side
his silence during Trump's impeachment
has enraged many john bolton was in the
room he didn't say anything he didn't
quit he didn't raise protests he didn't
do any whistleblowing he didn't go and
testify the Congress voluntarily he was
complicit despite having months to
review the book the White House is
rushing legal action to block its
release while simultaneously claiming it
to be a work of fiction and full of
classified information this is
despicable that he chose to publish this
book without fully going through the
review process Jackson Bolton seems to
have waited to put all his stuff in a
book and make money off it is it likely
to have any lasting impact well that's
the unknown in all of this Donna in many
ways what Bolton is saying echoes what
we've heard from other X administration
officials who essentially questioned
Trump's fitness for the job but at the
same time something about this coming
from Bolton has this White House rattled
you can tell that based on the lengths
they're going to to both discredit and
suppress the release of this book Donna
Jackson Carrasco in Washington thank you
the goal to erase racism coming up how
to Alberta communities are taking action
and forging important bonds
to communities in rural Alberta have
decided working together is the best
approach to address systemic racism the
Siksika First Nation is just east of
Calgary and most of its members attend
school and activities in the neighboring
town of Strathmore which is
predominantly white when tragedy struck
both the community's last year local
leaders decided things had to change
Heather Eurex West explains what
happened in life Christian a young man
was a bridge builder an accomplished
traditional dancer
KJ as he was known by friends and family
was passionate about his culture I
taught my children to be proud of who
they are and where they come from but it
was his other passion on the ice that
made KJ so well known beyond the Siksika
first nation as well so when one night
in March of 2019 a young man was shot
and killed both communities gathered to
mourn it was my boy our whole world
changed since then after two brothers
from Strathmore were charged in the
young man's death community leaders
began looking at how members of Siksika
had been experiencing racism in the
neighboring community things there were
comments about First Nations people
being followed more in some of the
stores as opposed to two non First
Nations the council's of Siksika and
Strathmore began meeting regularly to
come up with plans to address systemic
anti indigenous racism in the town a lot
of that goes back to just not knowing
you know a lot of people don't fully
understand what took place you know in
the residential schools a lot of people
don't fully understand the term 60 scoop
the initiative has also included the
local detachment of the RCMP they were
looking at things like what to do with
with the person if if they were in the
detachment if they were being held
overnight for example and and what to do
with the person to ensure that that that
person got home safely back to Siksika
nation we're working on you know trying
to develop some ride-alongs with the
RCMP develops some community watch
program
the work is still in its early days but
if successful its work both leaders feel
could be replicated in other communities
and its work melody a young man says
honors her son we need something in
place where we learn about each other
and this should have began a long time
ago Heather lyrics West Global News
Strathmore Alberta a Calgary woman has
filed a proposed class action lawsuit
against several well-known Canadian
cannabis companies for allegedly
incorrectly labeling the THC in CBD
levels in their products Aurora and
tilray are among the companies accused
of selling products with levels
drastically different than advertised
the proposed lawsuit claims many of the
cannabis products for sold in containers
with plastic bottles or caps that may
have degraded the level of potency other
products may have contained
significantly higher amounts than stated
causing unwanted effects the lawsuit is
seeking recovery of money spent on the
cannabis products and damages for
physical or mental injury reducing
infant asthma still ahead the new
research helping parents breathe easier
you are watching global national
more than 650 workers at one of
germany's largest meat processing plants
have tested positive for Kovan 19 the
facility was ordered to shut down nearby
schools have also closed at about 7,000
people in the area have been put into
quarantine the company says the outbreak
could be linked to recent travel by
workers after borders started to reopen
a government investigation has been
launched to trace what happened and in
China a public health expert now says a
new Koba 19 outbreak in Beijing is under
control 21 new cases were detected today
bringing the total to 158 most are
linked to a sprawling wholesale food
market that supplies about 80 percent of
the city's fresh fruit vegetables meat
and seafood new restrictions and
increased testing are in place this is
the worst kovat 19 outbreak in beijing
since early February Canadian research
shows childhood asthma rates have fallen
and the drop is attributed to less
antibiotic use in babies the study
published in The Lancet found infants
given antibiotics faced nearly double
the risk of asthma by age five
researchers in d.c analysed data from
about 225,000 kids up to the age of four
and found every 10% increase in the
prescription of antibiotics was linked
with a 24% increase in asthma rates the
study suggests careful antibiotic use in
children under the age of 1 is important
to help preserve the diversity and
abundance of healthy gut bacteria making
children less susceptible to developing
asthma later in life
asthma is the most common chronic
childhood disease in Canada
next the world sings the praises of the
late virile in there aren't many songs
that can cross generations and not many
voices remembered for raising morale and
helping heal a nation tributes are
pouring in for Dame virile in who has
died at the age of 103 her music came to
life during the Second World War
delivering hope in bleak times and then
spanned the decades songs like we'll
meet again taking on new meaning in the
pandemic crystal commencing looks back
at her extraordinary life her voice
likened to honey ingested by millions
needing to be soothed but I know
[Music]
some sunny day where people use the word
icon loosely nowadays but tingling was
truly an icon I just think she had this
inner spark that that kind of when don't
give up you know someone who's still
talking about hope for the future when
they're 100 has to have an incredible
spark in within them
[Music]
Dame virile in spent most of her 103
years singing by 14 she was being booked
for parties and events in her 20s with
her wartime anthem we'll meet again she
became the force's Sweetheart and took
to the airwaves every Sunday with the
BBC radio show Sincerely Yours there's
so much we all wanted to say to you so
much was saving up for our moments
together again that sweetness lapped up
by the masses still the show had its
critics some fear it was too mellow and
had a drugging effect on men in battle
her passing has been marked by
politicians Boris Johnson tweeting her
voice will live on to lift the hearts of
generations to come Prince Charles
shared old photos and captain Tom Moore
beloved in his own right wrote she had a
huge impact on me in Burma and remained
important to me throughout my life her
songs movies and memoirs may have a
timestamp in history but she remained
current and connected that's her with
the Spice Girls promoting poppy sales
don't you think the you are the original
Spice Girl yes I suppose I was really
many moons ago that smile and spark of
Dame virile in captured countless times
on and off the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
miss toga man Singh global news London
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm donor Friesen tonight's
your Canada is the sunset over Penticton
BC thanks for watching a Robin Gill will
be here tomorrow and I will see you on
Sunday for the new reality take care of
yourselves
bye bye
[Music]